with over 95 million habitants Egypt is
the biggest country in the Arab world
and yes I know what you're thinking
aren't Indonesia and Pakistan bigger
than Egypt but they Muslim - well yes
they are if you make no mistake there is
a difference between Arab and Muslim
Islam is simply a religion while Arabic
is a culture a race and especially a
language and inside this Arab world
Egypt isn't only the most populous
country it's one of the most influential
this is why the Arab League has its
headquarters on the Tahrir Square in the
very center of Cairo and why news like
this is so worrying death toll in egypt
rises to 305 people in their deadliest
terrorist attack nonetheless despite the
latest news egypt is changing faster
than we might think
maybe he remember the Arab Spring in
2011 thousands of people protested for
days to overthrow Hosni Mubarak the
dictator who ruled the country back then
a year later the Muslim Brotherhood
gains power ready to turn the country
into the pyramids of an Islamic Republic
but now in 2017 Egyptian politics are
taking a 180 degree shift Egyptian
government closes 27,000 mosques and
moved to fight terrorism so now the
question becomes well how did we get
here and is Egypt to becoming a secular
country well today we're going to answer
those questions but before we do let's
take a look back at the history
the Muslim Brotherhood there are three
names who define Egypt's history in the
last 60 years NASA set out and Mubarak
these three politicians have a common
ingredients they were all dictators that
followed the principles of Arab
socialism
this was the trendy ideology back then a
cocktail that combined a centralized
economy authoritarian leadership and
secularism must make no mistake as
socialist as they claim to be none of
those leaders had any problem with
changing their rubles into dollars as
soon as the Soviet Union disappeared in
fact Sadat recognized the State of
Israel hands during the 1980s Egypt was
already an ally of America
and as you know before ending America in
this part of the world puts you on the
radical Islamist bullseye this is white
mubarik prosecuted every Islamic
movement part of this repression was to
avoid the terrorist attacks that became
pretty frequent in the 1990s but Mubarak
also had other motivations he wanted to
stop any potential challenge to his
authoritarian rule and guess who the
only organised group who could replace
him was well yes that would be the
Muslim Brotherhood despite being a
clandestine movement since 1954 the
Muslim Brotherhood is the most organized
grassroots organization since Egypt's
independence until today
they have thousands of members and
millions of sympathizers the goal is to
turn each if into an Islamic Republic
compliant with Sharia law and the
principles of the Koran nonetheless the
Muslim Brotherhood isn't the only
radical group in this country here we
can also find the Salafist supersu in
the same goals but by different means
the guys you see on the screen out then
was in brothers as you can see they
dress in a very Western fashion
jeans t-shirts hoodies etc now these
other guys are the Salafist members do
you see the difference Salafis have
traditional Muslim clothes beards and
the zebra bar on their foreheads created
after hitting the ground so many times
while praying to Mecca as you can
probably figure out from their name the
Salafis want to live like the first
Muslims the so called Salaf did however
the Muslim brothers are way more
pragmatic and better organized their
members infiltrate government
institutions and they have no problem
disguising their intentions when they
speak to the Western media we are not
terrorists the Muslim Brotherhood's
philosophy is inspired by an
understanding of Islam that emphasizes
the values of social justice equality
and the rule of law jihad al Haddad
spokesperson for the Muslim Brotherhood
in other words both the Salafis and
Muslim Brotherhood have the same goals
but different strategies today the
Salafists have a political party called
al noor and this has nothing to do with
the muslim brothers as you can imagine
the radicals don't like each other very
much remember this because we will come
back to it later anyway during the 1980s
the military dictatorship of Hosni
Mubarak attacked both of these groups in
fact since the Year 1981 Egypt has been
in a never-ending state of emergency
where every political dissident is sent
to jail
this means thousands of Salafists and
Muslim brothers spending decades behind
bars and as you can imagine neither the
European Union nor the United States did
anything to stop this at the end of the
day nobody wanted to see the Islamic
radicals in the government if this was
not enough after the Yom Kippur War
Egypt had become a good ally of Israel
and their economy it was on fire
think about it this country has all the
ingredients for a world-class tourism
industry the pyramids the Nile the
desert the Red Sea you can say that by
the year 2000 you couldn't label
yourself a traveller if you didn't have
an Egyptian stamp on your passport so
for 30 years Mubarak had a free pass
through Egypt but wait just a second
because in 2011 things really changed
Oryx signals Egypt succession by taking
son to Washington news like this one
made both the citizens and some factions
of the army equally enraged having a
dictator is one thing having a
hereditary dynasty of power is quite
another this is how the Arab Spring came
to Egypt's and why Mubarak had to resign
a year later parliamentary and
presidential elections were housed we're
talking about a country that has spent
decades under a dictatorship a country
where the only strong political
movements other than the government
itself where the Salafists and the
Muslim Brotherhood so guess who won
those elections yes it was the Muslim
Brotherhood led by the guy you see on
the screen now Mohamed Morsi
but wait a minute because things are way
more complex unless you are Saudi Arabia
and you are sitting on a pile of oil
radical Islam isn't good for managing an
economy so in less than one year Egypt's
economy
it absolutely sank thousands of people
lost their jobs and inflation
skyrocketed meanwhile morsi's main goal
was to ISM eyes the government stopped
the division of power and shield his own
power then you've got out into this
equation the army as we said before
Egyptian defense forces on no big fan of
Islamist groups and this is our new
player came into the picture
marshal abdel fattah el seesi was the
head of the Egyptian Armed Forces
p-nut the leaders of the opposing
parties including the Salafists and
basically said something like okay so
look Morsi and his friends they're
really screwing up the government help
me set up a coup d'etat and we can put
things back in order and as we say here
a visual politic as it was said sir was
done land of the Pharaohs by the year
2030 in the Egyptian army kicked Morsi
out of the governments their first
policy was to make the Muslim
Brotherhood an illegal organization
again of course
protesters went to the streets and
hundreds of them died and thousands of
them were sent to jail but in June of
2014 new elections were held and I say
elections here because there was
virtually a single candidate Allah cc
and he managed to get 97 percent of the
vote
the other acceptive candidate was a guy
with a zero percent chance of winning
called hamdeen sabahi
he got the other three percent of the
vote so maybe you've seen the movie The
Dark Knight there's this amazing quote
it says you either die a hero or you
live long enough to see yourself become
the villain well this could have been
coined by LCCC himself in fact in past
few years Egypt has become the world's
number one leader in people given the
death penalty but not only that in just
three years the government has closed
over 27,000 mosques further there is no
freedom of speech whatsoever
and yes I know you're thinking here the
Islamic fanatics are pretty angry about
this
well actually the opposite is true
remember how I said that the Salafists
and the Muslim brothers aren't good
friends well I was definitely not
kidding about that Egypt's ultra
conservative Islamist back Isis seek to
eclipse Brotherhood but wait just a
minute because things are not good for
the Salafists either
of course LCC gave them enough freedom
so they could fill the roles left by the
Muslim brothers but those Egyptian
believers who want to go to a mosque
have to go to those controlled by the L
as ha inmates which is under
governmental control but you know what
the biggest Balan is here there are less
and less believers in Egypt the
percentage of youngsters who pray daily
has halved in less than five years
according to the Arab barometer in the
year 2011 84% of the population
supported Sharia law influencing
politics in 2016 that percentage fell to
34% but not only that al Sisi himself
celebrates the Christian Christmas in
the Coptic Cathedral of Cairo year after
year
in other words Egyptian society it's
becoming more and more secular but
before you get too excited wait just a
moment because this could change at any
moment first of all LCCC's popularity
fell in 2017 a good share of Egyptians
do not like the fact that he gave Saudi
Arabia sovereignty over two islands in
the Red Sea they also don't like the
repression either in fact news like this
kind of resembles mujer X times e [ __ ]
declares state of emergency after deadly
church attacks on the other hands the
economy is most Egyptians name worried
despite the unemployment rate still
going down it's still over 12% and these
are the official figures some experts
say that it might be over 20 and despite
all of this the government is working on
fairer like projects Egypt build new
capital paid for by Trainor add to this
the terrorist attacks and we can only
conclude that LCCC's government is
failing more than it is succeeding
so now the question is do you believe
Egypt can turn into a secular country
the way neighbouring to knizia did or do
you think he'll see sees government is
DejaVu of Mubarak's and that eventually
we will see a brand new Arab Spring in
this country well please leave your
answer in the comments below we'd love
to hear from you and if you want to know
what happened in Tunisia well do check
out this other video and of course visit
our friends at reconsider media they
provide deep vocals in this episode that
are not mine and don't forget to
subscribe we publish brand new videos
every single week so hit that subscribe
button and catch every post and also if
you like this video please give it a
thumbs up and as always I'll see you
next time and if you want to learn more
about politics and here even more of my
lovely voice you can join us at
reconsider media we have a podcast at
reconsider mediacom slash podcast see
you there